used with no dye or fillers because we
live in an
age of plastics from the ocean shore
to the himalayas the planet is littered
with bags bottles and other objects born
from plastic
at times it seems plastic trash will
haunt us for centuries
if not millennia yet not all plastic
leftovers are durable or worthless
in fact museum conservators are fishing
for ways to prevent priceless plastic
artifacts
from breaking down nearly every museum
in the world
houses plastic objects vintage phones
disney films the first artificial heart
these and other plastic artifacts are
made of synthetic polymers
that are vulnerable to decay unstable
plastics can be found in things like
early billiard balls
old legos and foam art masterpieces from
the 60s
over time these plastic materials and
even fairly stable ones like pet
found in water bottles and food
packaging can degrade
sometimes oozing out additives and
melting into sludge
oxygen heat and light are often
implicated in this carnage
but different plastics respond
differently to such environmental
factors
because plastics come in so many
varieties
conservators sometimes can't tell
exactly what materials are in their
collections
which can hinder efforts to preserve
artifacts
some conservators have used sensory data
such as the sound
feel and smell of plastics to tease out
the material's identities
a vinegary scent for instance signals
cellulose acetate
celluloid one of the earliest of
plastics conservators also have turned
to controlled experiments
to get a grasp on how plastic artifacts
degrade
one study simulated the plastic fabrics
in modern raincoats
you might think that storing them at the
coldest possible temperature
would best preserve them but these
fabrics turn brittle
and were packed with holes after deep
freeze storage
storing them at a milder 4.4 degrees
celsius
prevented this problem still running
experiments to help preserve museum
objects can be tricky
over the decades modern plastic
manufacturers
have switched up their recipes for
making polymers
they now add ingredients such as
stabilizers and flame retardants
old plastics didn't contain those
ingredients so conservators who want to
save
older polymers need to make historically
accurate versions
to test out their conservation methods
with this in mind
scientists at the getty conservation
institute paged through old tray
magazines
and dug up the exact ingredients of past
plastics recipes
after mimicking the recipes the
scientists are now running stress tests
on their new old plastics with an eye
toward artificial aging tests down the
line
saving plastic artifacts is more than a
matter of nostalgia
these objects may serve as time capsules
for future civilizations to understand
our own
just as stone tools have taught us about
the stone age
losing these ubiquitous strands of
polymers
could mean losing a human era to
antiquity
are only two of the many plastics now in
[Music]
[Music]
you